now some student athletes need
references to get accepted by a college
the air force academy requires
a united states congressman's
recommendation arbor view's devin
ramirez flies at a different level
to play football for the air force you
can't just be a talented player you have
to be an elite young man
everything about ramirez is the real
deal the scholar athlete activates a
no-fly zone in the secondary and can
come to the line of scrimmage and tackle
too
he's even growing out his hair for locks
of love our review has a tradition of
great football devon
is open to future plans but has an
interest in aeronautical engineering
either way when it comes to this future
cadet the sky is the limit
i would say the best part of all this
was probably when i got the phone call
of
that telling me that i got an official
offer and that was just mind-blowing
because i never i never imagined that
i'd be able to play d1 one day
and then that was that was just crazy to
me i've always dreamed of playing
college football so the fact that i'm
finally achieving that goal is just mind
blowing to me and i was just
overwhelmed with excitement i just
couldn't believe that i finally got to
this point in my life and
i just can't wait to get started both my
grandfather served so
that's important to me serving my
country something that i'm glad to do
knowing that i have a place to play next
year especially since we didn't play
this this past year like not having a
season so being able to still continue
my football career i would say is the
most rewarding
remember the name devin ramirez